[Music]
his reign marked the beginning of one of
history's greatest empires and the end
of one of its first republics was Rome's
first emperor a visionary leader who
guaranteed his civilizations place in
history or a tyrant who destroyed its
core values find out in history versus
Augustus order order the defendant today
is Gaius Octavius Gaius Oh Julius Caesar
do we have the wrong guy no your honor
Gaius Octavius born in 63 BCE was the
grand nephew of Julius Caesar
he became Gaius Julius Caesar upon being
named his great uncle's adoptive son and
heir and he gained the title Augustus in
27 BCE when the Senate granted him
additional honors you mean when he
established sole authority and became
emperor of Rome is that bad
didn't every place have some king or
Emperor back then actually your honor
the Roman people had overthrown their
Kings centuries before to establish a
republic a government meant to serve the
people not the privilege of a ruling
family and it was Octavius who destroyed
this tradition Octavius was a model
public servant at 16 he was elected to
the College of pontiff's that supervised
religious worship he fought for Rome in
espana alongside his great uncle Caesar
and took up the responsibility of
avenging Caesars death when the corrupt
oligarchs in the Senate betrayed and
murdered him Caesar had been a
power-hungry tyrant who tried to make
himself a king while consorting with his
Egyptian queen Cleopatra after his death
Octavius joined his general Mark Antony
in starting a civil war that tore Rome
apart then stabbed his ally in the fact
to increase his own Antony was a fool he
waged a disastrous campaign in pathya
and plotted to turn Roman territories
into personal kingdoms for himself and
Cleopatra isn't that what Caesar had
been accused of well so Octavius
destroyed Antony for trying to become a
king and then became one himself that's
right you can see the megalomania even
in his adopted title the illustrious one
that was a religious honorific
and Augustus didn't seek power for his
own sake as winner of the Civil War and
commander of the most troops it was his
duty to restore law and order to Rome so
that other factions didn't continue
fighting
he didn't restore the law he made it
subordinate to him not true Augustus
worked to restore the Senate's prestige
improved food security for the lower
classes and relinquished control of the
army when he resigned his consul post
mere optics he used his military
influence and personal wealth to stack
the Senate in his favor while retaining
the powers of a Tribune and the right to
celebrate military trials he kept
control of provinces with the most
legions and if that wasn't enough he
assumed the Consul position twice more
to promote his grandchildren he was
clearly trying to establish a dynasty
but what did he do with all that power
glad you asked your honor Augustus his
accomplishments were almost too many to
name
he established consistent taxation for
all provinces ending private
exploitation by local tax officials he
personally financed a network of roads
and employed couriers so news and troops
could travel easily throughout the realm
and it was under Augustus that many of
Rome's famous public buildings were
constructed the writers of the time were
nearly unanimous in praising his rule
did the writers have any other choice
Augustus exiled plenty of people on
vague charges including avec one of
Rome's greatest poets and you forgot to
mention the intrusive laws regarding
citizens personal lives
punishing adultery restricting marriage
between social classes even penalties
for remaining unmarried he was trying to
improve the citizenry and instill
discipline and he succeeded his legacy
speaks for itself
40 years of internal stability a
professional army that expanded Rome's
frontiers in all directions and a
government still remembered as a model
of civic virtue his legacy was an empire
that would go on to wage endless
conquest until it collapsed and a
tradition of military autocracy any time
a dictator in a generals uniform commits
atrocities while claiming to act on
behalf of the people we have Augustus
Caesar
to thank so you're saying Augustus was a
good Emperor and you're saying there's
no such thing we're used to celebrating
historical leaders for their
achievements and victories but to ask
whether an individual should have such
power in the first place is to put
history itself on trial check out this
playlist for more episodes of our
history verses series where we put
famous figures like Cleopatra Vladimir
Lenin and Genghis Khan on trial
[Music]